[Musique]
beat feuz joli rendez-vous 145 1
messieurs conserver ses secrets
je t'ai étaient des faux pour toujours
il n'y aura que nous deux et on disait
que c'est rêver on savait que c'était
faux on s'était promis l'impossible je
l'admets je connais le prénom de nos
enfants qui ne mettront jamais et si la
vie est belle alors la course est dure
et notre amour n'était pas qu'un amour
d'été on s'était partagé nos pensées pas
café con way dans votre belle idylle
avant que vienne la baisse on s'était
promis qu'on ferait le tour du monde
maintenant on va le faire chacun en sens
inverse et je veux faire de proposition
et vous allez devoir trouver qui se
cache derrière le rideau
attention je vais regarder
qu'est-ce que je ne vois vite
est ce que je viens de voir booba liste
aux dires le sosie de booba en train de
manger à baillif tôt cette fois c'est bh
que j'ai vu date jus d'orange
ces dates jus qui boit un jus d'orange
pressé ou est ce que j'ai vu blackman m
aa c'est à dire black m avec un
personnage amène m alors à votre avis la
grippe même déjà c'est sûr que non parce
que je suis en train de lui parler
actuellement la promesse âge look black
ops the line regarde à la télé là c'est
pas blake est envoyée il est en pleine
promo et tout donc c'est qu'ils n'ont
pas à l'état d'où tu as tu joues au bout
et êtes-vous frey dit khalil alors ils
travaillent à jouer autre chose à faire
donc c'est le sosie de booba oui je
pensais que ses amis avaient choisi de
booba le sosie booba ouais non pas des
yeux vous pouvez regarder toile et
chaussées une banane tout parti qui se
cache dans le rideau bloqués
[Applaudissements]
sa maman faire
il y passera tout il avait vu dans fort
boyard pour être avec vous on vous
emmerde pas les bras merci allez vous
asseoir et brasse et là vous inquiétez
pas ce qui va avoir d'autres surprises
qui se cache derrière le rideau
la côté est folle c'est vous la deuxième
personne qui se fait dans l'eure le
rhino la peta est folle folle à votre
avis est ce que je vois m pokora by
jacob à dire encore à déguiser en rabbi
jacob ou bien j'aimerais bien est ce que
je vois la roue soprano s'agit de
soprano avec la coupe de la chanteuse
larusso
je sais que les gars frère votre avis
tout est bien tout et qu'il y ait
derrière le rideau chez vous à votre
avis non mais sow n'enrichit soprano
sano super pote vraiment recette a nommé
si nadal est logique c'est la team la
tanzanie la presse de parler là
j'imagine aussi un non mais ça va mais
des fois où le web pokora moi je dirais
un vu qu'on connaît bien
mais ce proche qui servait aussi avec la
coupe à la rousseau ouais on est dans du
schiste vu indigne en afrique c'est ça
owen au bras on va regarder tout de
suite qu'ils savaient qu'ils pouvaient
c'est quoi
son propre capital
allah
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
à côté
va raconter l'histoire de
téléspectateurs on t'a fait une surprise
on t'a fait une blague et pâques c'est
le cas bien compris qu il lance des
douilles balance qui valorise moeurs qui
excusez moi c'est bip fait au lit moi je
te propose qu'on balance à magnéto
qu'est ce t'en dis alors parce que j'ai
vue mercredi après j'ai sur les réseaux
sociaux il ya plein de gens qui disaient
il ya big flo et oli dans le public il
paraît que vous étiez dans le public
bref très roulante a fait une surprise
on s'est caché dans le poser dans le
public est à rien car nous n'en avons
n'était pas non plus hyper bien déguisé
pourquoi c'est vrai ce que vous n'avez
pas dû croiser mon regard intrus cobas
non tu verras nous a pas regardés bas
matin dans tu rigoles jazz et bien tu
verras parce qu'il m'a dit ça tout à
l'heure dans la ligue ouais mais c'est
bon moi je vous aurais capter direct
avant et je vous le dis j'ai vu il était
dans le public et j'ai vu des photos
après deux dans le public grimés chili
mais les mecs chine aurait vu les
matches c'est qu'elle est directe voir
nous aurait cramé
[Musique]
olala pointu
je m'appelle dédié je suis agent
d'assurance j'ai 43 ans ça fait cinq ans
que j'ai ouvert ma propre agence
je m'appelle césar directeur du festival
latino-américain à toulouse et à plein
et a plein de maille aujourd'hui rage
houle dit on est sur plein de dossiers
dans un instant
on parlera thierry ghillani comme tous
les jours un regard celui qui se
présente à la mairie de paris
je sais qu'il ya des pluies diluviennes
dans le sud lorsque les comptes absent
non tombent directement d'ailleurs soir
des choses cela nouvelles têtes et ça va
fonctionner
regardez
[Musique]
mais c'est la faute à la photo elle est
incroyable parce que tu me regardez pas
tapé tapé koulou a été trop gentil tu as
dit comment tu t'appelles
il y est sympa mais les gens qui connaît
pas ça c'est vrai mais quand on est allé
dans la roche tout est là tu as fait
mais les gars je vous aurais capter
directement
on a fait des photos avec toute l'équipe
mon gars c'est un hymne devise alors
très honnêtement quand je me suis rassis
je me suis dit ils disent quelque chose
ça doit être des habitués de l'émission
a dit que c'était à moi de me parler
mais hyper sympa mais comment ça va ça
se passe bien je dis oui au top tu vois
les photos que les deux gars pendant que
derrière il avait grillé il ya quelques
personnes du public qui avait grillé et
y avait quelques chronicles aussi qu'il
y avait beaucoup avaient pas demandé de
ciani tu nous as grille alors les chéris
c'est vrai que mine de rien moi je vous
trouve avant pour voir les tetes s'il
vous plaît parce que c'est vrai que mine
de rien voilà moi je mais c'est vrai que
vous regardez vous ne regardiez pas dans
les yeux il est mauvais joueur peut on
peut au tna mais en plus quand tu es
dans quand tu es concentré dans la
négresse voit pas dit rien mais nous on
était cachée en 4e derrière ça avance et
cacher les civils
le cateau
oh
hahaha
forte
avec nous on aura deux enfants une villa
sur la mer pour toujours tout le temps
les promesses les promesses et promet on
à
deux enfants
une villa
sur la mer
pour tous
tout le temps
les promesses des promesses et
promettent
qui connaît le mieux les pmp entre big
flo et oli et les chroniqueurs de tpm
pays alors attention on lève la main big
flo et oli duras big flo et oli où les
chroniqueurs de tpm pay attention big
flo et oli et il peut jouer aussi fabien
turpaud à jouer quels invités qui est
venu le plus souvent dompter pmp kelly
malik bentalha ben ali ben talha vous
vous dites quoi je dirais que gad
elmaleh hégémonie mettez vous d'accord
d'humoristes c'est sûr bentallah
bentalha donc comme kelly n'est pas
comme kelly diam un truc qui vous dit tu
m'as égalité qui est pas y aller d ouais
ça a édité un truc moi j'ai reagan
garder le match ghana et bien je vais
vous dire qu'en troisième position c'est
malik bentalha en deuxième position
c'est karine lemarchand franck dubosc et
stéphane rotenberg est l'invité qui est
venu le plus dans tp mpc kev adams c'est
toi il est venu c'est ce pauvre oui
attention quelques chroniqueurs un
talents de ventriloque
on avait fait un jour dans l'ordre
incroyable talent oui ma moi c'est pas
bon c'était pas jean-luc lemoine
non jean michel maire non mais bon j'ai
l'impression que personne ne connaît
cette fille mais là c'est toi mais c'est
d'ailleurs c'était benjamin castaldi
dans l'émission les chroniqueurs ont un
incroyable mais lui sait pas ou pas et
comment il peut pas être au courant s'il
se voit même pas lui-même
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ça va castaldi et son numéro de
ventriloquie
[Applaudissements]
comment tu t'appelles même le cadreur
regarder attention les cherry pour
l'instant il ya zéro point par sarah
chaussures s'adapte sourire qu'elle
chante revenant dans le queens avec le
roi parce que là je vois que ça prend
pas ces duels chanteuse
j'ai accueilli sur le plateau en ayant
10 5 minutes avant nicole c'est cela
comment dix ans j'avais été cueillis sur
le plateau
c'est quoi cette merde
[Applaudissements]
c'est que cette merde la caisse car
mettez moi quelque chose d'ouvert
c'était quoi ça tient ou plus en régie
par les nicole qui ça assez les pussycat
dolls
rethel ou des points qu'on connaît ya
nicole scherzinger qui n'ont pas nous
voir toute la
[Applaudissements]
j'adore cette chanson chanson j'en
rigolais j'adore tout petit je connais
toutes les parts
[Applaudissements]
je compatis parce que ça m'est arrivé à
moto si j'étais dans un hub est à paris
et le mec m'a pas reconnue c'est souvent
mon frère quand on connaît le plus
j'étais comme ça avec une capuche et il
y avait un sens qui passait dans une
radio connu qui passe du rap
ouais kelly c'est vraiment de la merde
me flaud n'en arrête sa dîme route a dit
gérard mais dix étaient comme ça pas
bien tu que je dise quoi c'est moi alors
je voulais qu'ils venaient de commencer
sa part cyril ça parle lequel des deux
reports et répond le mois à vos messages
dd c'est grave c'est flou c'est los
lobos et font le plein de voix il répond
tu sais un jour après c'est pour dire
une grosse connerie sur des conneries
s'ils sont d'accord tous les deux dans
les défis auxquels des deux fait le plus
attention à son look
flo chloé ça reste flou c'est flou la
dernière fois sur saône instagram il a
sorti une chemise c'est frérot il en est
cette chimie n'est pas compliqué dit
merci
la même alors vous dit wes de la
production on vient de confectionner
attention lequel des deux est le plus
bosseurs lequel des deux travaillent au
plus assez serré la d2 c'est serré les
deux les deux ils travaillent beaucoup
quand même
jerbi ya un truc que les gens savent ou
ne savent pas sont pas au courant c'est
flou c'est les compos des instruits
ouais même à poser des d instruction mon
album de la musique sur les albums ça
c'est vrai moi j'ai envie de dire devant
tout le monde que c'est mon frère qui
transpirait c'est vrai c'est vrai vous
sur sa main s'est prêtée à l'heure où
tape dessus mais quand même faut lui
dire tout cas les gars c'est blake est
mais ce prénom qu'il parle de moi là je
suis comme un vase lequel des deux a le
plus de plus la cote avec les meufs
loterie baratine il n'a même pas besoin
d'y réfléchir blagues sur connerie parce
que il est marrant tu aurais hall il est
un peu plus tu le connais un peu plus
timide c'est ça la journée il évoque ses
petits orifices n'était pas à m'écrire
un message aux célibataires frère lequel
des deux est le plus radin mon avis les
gars à mon avis vous pouvez savoir un
peu cette crise et qui pour toi j'arrive
pas tu dirais qui vu la mantide flosi
comolli ouais ouais ouais ouais
les frères c'est un malade ah ouais
c'est ça les gars mais c'est pas économe
[Rires]
ils paradent à l'école et franchement
toi tu trouves tu es le plus radin j'ai
pas suffira d'un frère mais pas avec ses
potes et tout mais pour lui ferait il se
fait zéro plaisir c'est ça c'est vrai
chez lui la veille avait quasiment pas
un meuble pendant un an et demi c'est
pareil il s'assoit chez lui il regarde
tes pump et tout ce qui fait je me
contente de simplicité tata l'amour est
ce que tu penses aussi au premier
rendez-vous les promesses d'aujourd'hui
est pas celle de la veille la terrasse
était pleine mais on voyait que nous tu
m'as dit je ferai un café gens voient
jamais j'ai dit pareil on n'a même pas
fini les films qu'on a commencé de notre
coeur de pierre blessés des étincelles
rien n'avait de sens quand la confiance
était fiancé l'amour transforme les
luttes il en est essentielle dans tes
yeux j'étais moi m'ont parfois sur des
cibles tu changé mon matelas encore
ange tombé du ciel peu d terme et dément
plus je te disais tellement je t'aime
c'était presque ton prénom est tout ça
c'est terminé
pas facile de se faire à l'idée que ça
fait une éternité qu'on s'est trop mis
l'éternité dans les promesses sont des
mensonges tout ce désenchantement
l'amour de jeunesse c'est croire que
dans tout le valais
toutes les mains en l'air c'est comme ça
on la regarde de loin aux faits
[Applaudissements]
m
ces mots ont leur langue
[Applaudissements]
la blonde
[Musique]
il est là
alors merci serait franchement je pense
commentaires des très grandes marques ce
soir merci à fabien non non non et qui
ont regardé moi non mais oui entendent
en tant que porte tissé en tant que
femme je le trouve magnifique
honnêtement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
changer
non
à
[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]